victoria legislativa para by the end con
219 votos a favor y 112 en contra la
cámara de representantes aprobó el plan
de ayuda que el presidente demócrata
había prometido para combatir la crisis
económica dejada por la pandemia 1900
billones de dólares destinados a comprar
vacunas y equipo médico pero también a
reactivar la economía por ejemplo
incluye pagos directos de 1.400 dólares
a millones de familias 400 dólares
semanales para desempleados y el punto
más polémico aumentar el salario mínimo
a 15 dólares la hora el proyecto de ley
que recibió apoyo prácticamente unitario
de la bancada demócrata deberá aprobarse
en el senado no tenemos tiempo que
perder si actuamos ahora de manera
decisiva rápida y valiente podremos por
fin tomarle ventaja a este virus
podremos por fin poner en marcha nuestra
economía la batalla política en el
senado se prevé más compleja el paquete
de ayudas sólo necesita mayoría simple
para que se apruebe una mayoría en manos
demócratas por un estrecho margen sin
embargo la cámara alta- declaró que
necesitaba una mayoría más amplia
para modificar algo tan esencial como el
salario mínimo
eso significa que bailén debería
renunciar a ese punto si quiere aprobar
el resto de ayudas los republicanos se
han opuesto frontalmente al proyecto
legislativo numbers la cantidad de
dinero que realmente se dedica a la
lucha contra el virus es menos del 9 por
ciento no lo llamen ley de rescate o ley
de alivio
las encuestas muestran que la población
estadounidense aprueba ampliamente este
plan una de las puntas de lanza de la
campaña de bailén